I'm your superhero right yeah you need
more stuff hey ya name it needs more
stuff thanks thanks mark thank you thank
you just close this very what's that
supposed to mean my clothes are very
would you don't need you betcha it's
okay you have the other closet listen
you're a little person your clothes are
tinier than mine I gotta back up and
give you guys a proper tour what's up
everyone happy weekend so Nina and I
have just bought a new condo we've been
on the fence on what to do Nina wants a
house I want a condo I don't like the
maintenance of a house Nina like the
space and also having a backyard to
plant her stuff so what we decided I was
to get a bigger condo so the unit that
we bought is 1,450 square feet and today
is our final visit to go check it out
tomorrow is our closing and so we
thought we'll take you along on the
journey to check out the place we don't
know any yet so there's probably gonna
be other people's stuff in there but
yeah super excited in and I have a buzz
all excited to get this deal done
tomorrow and you can join us on our trip
to see the condo on our last what is it
last inspection what's a call when you
get a day you get two days in the
contract right pre-delivery inspection
anyway whatever exciting
so i made a video so you know no the
extra shirt today okay extra sure you
need to be a minute video at home
talking what we're doing and I said that
you know I don't really like condos
named alexa condo it's for her basically
me right okay right like the condos
wasted for Nina but they know I'm
happening it's for the wife right we're
gonna do it for her right yeah right
great we're sitting waiting for our
meals digit to show up and the security
guard likes my jacket I mean this
vitamin think we need to take two I'm
your superhero right yeah let's go let's
go this is mark marcola hand he's gonna
get little emergency see Martin yes
we love you so much mark is the finest
real estate agent in Toronto this is
what I think last time we sent his
brother though it's okay and we're going
to team I know but we miss mark let's
relative nothing but he's not Marc
Marquez and magic mark brings the magic
like Nina Nina brings magic to what kind
of magic other kind of magic denmark I
gotta back up and give you guys a proper
tour okay Nina I give the tour this is
the day / Pete interim pretty big ten by
ten it's messy you don't have to have
waited hey that's important rush if
there wasn't a toilet
this is the launcher all right moving on
kitchen
this is the master Nina gets two closets
regular closet you're in the second and
she gets the walk-in closet I don't get
close what's that supposed to mean my
clothes are very one unique fetch it's
okay you have the other cloth listen
you're a little person your clothes are
tinier than mine yeah it's hers and hers
Nina and Nina oh the good old the roomba
we have stories about rumbas we need to
all right then we've got this will be
the dining area here yeah yeah we need
to buy a light and then this is the huge
living room what's our what's the view
here tell sweats in there is the CN
Tower huge space here okay then we got
patio Nina's going to grow some plain
set here hi future neighbors alright and
then the very exciting part guys this is
it done this is the exciting room this
is Evans office oh yeah have to figure
out the your class coordination a turd
in mine listen you get two closets okay
you can't complain about my table it
that's small wait this is way smaller
dose listen to Marty this is a perfect
size for mine you didn't know this would
be the cleanest bathroom ever cuz it's
only Evans bathroom now you have to
clean up your own mess then we gotta
figure out where we're gonna put the
believe wall in here am I gonna work
facing the window probably so when we
came last time Mark's brother said we
should be looking for signs of them
moving out and at that time they had not
moved anything out now looks like
they say there's their science
you need more stuff yeah a meanie may
need some more stuff thanks thanks mark
thank you thank you oh ok chandelier can
you doubt the one that they insisted on
keeping they broke you could have just
left it well maybe they'll leave us this
one not that I'm a huge fan of it anyway
it's not very pretty either I don't like
that wire in the middle hanging down we
can find something better we like it
high five boom boom boom boom it's all
over the place the 5 5 s are we but the
place is solid alright well thank you
for joining us we will give further
updates as we move in maybe we'll film
the moving in what do you think you know
be freaking out there's nothing like
adding of a camera to the day when
you're moving in right I think it
reduces stress and just adds a lot more
fun one hundred percent ok we'll see